hillary clinton did an interview with
the financial times
it was a fascinating interview i read
some of it you know
at times i was asleep i'm not going to
lie dozed off here and there but tried
to keep my eyeballs open my husband
brought some toothpicks out so i could
pry them open for most of it but she did
make some good points i'm not gonna lie
i was looking for the common ground guys
i was looking in there to see can
hillary clinton and i find some common
ground so let's see if we did
this is a little summary of the
interview from the daily mail it says
hillary clinton warns democrats fixation
with transgender issues and condemning
jk rowling could cost them the upcoming
midterms and 2024 presidential election
huh that peaked my interest when i saw
that headline let's read a little bit
hillary clinton warned that democrats
insistence on focusing on these issues
could cost them the election look the
most important thing is to win the next
election the alternative is so
frightening that whatever does not help
you win should not be a priority why is
the alternative frightening i have to
ask
is freedom that frightening to her yes
yes it is
this is one of my favorite parts because
they say that it could cost if hillary
if the democrats don't win the next
election it could cost america democracy
itself i love the drama which is really
interesting from a crowd that advocated
for segregation against people who
didn't want to get an experimental
vaccine suddenly they love democracy
again okay
let's accept that and move on just for
time's sake
hillary's comments came just days after
president biden signed an executive
order to make gender affirming care that
can involve hormone therapy and surgery
while accusing republican lawmakers of
bullying lgbtq plus children
okay so i think hillary has a point here
i think she's right
that these cultural issues
are going to bury democrats not just i
think we need to look at the midterms
before we get to the next presidential
election i think this is going to be a
huge problem i think she knows it i
think she knows that parents around the
country are saying
i don't want my preschooler to be
lectured about sex education from a drag
queen at storytelling hour okay things
have gone a little mad
most people around the country are a
little unsettled by this information and
i think she knows that
i think they're also raising eyebrows at
gender reassignment surgery in children
and what the implications of that can be
parents are now asking a lot of
questions
because i don't think they realized how
crazy things had gotten truly until the
mandates for the vaccine came in and i
think everything after that they started
to have open eyes like what's going on
when it comes to gender because this
used to be these used to be issues that
affected adults
we used to talk about these things with
respect to an adult conversation and now
it's like no we need the kids we need
the kids let's go for the kids and
people are very protective of their
children i don't care what your
political ideology is everyone across
the political spectrum can say you come
from my kid i'm coming for you so that's
a commonality that we all share now
let's be clear about hillary clinton for
a second
she's not saying that these things could
be a problem because she has a problem
with them she's not saying i disagree
with the crazy she's saying don't put
the crazy front and center because if
you put the crazy front and center
you're not going to get reelected so i
don't know how she feels about these
issues for all i know she backs all this
crazy policy i have no idea you'd have
to ask her but i don't think that's what
she's saying i think she's saying
put stuff front and center that's
palatable to people
that they feel that you're not the party
of the crazy that you're not the party
of aoc who's talking about menstruating
people we broke that down yesterday but
aoc says stuff like that that's a turn
off to people who have brains who are
sane who are middle of the road and who
aren't looking for activism at every
level of society
they don't want indoctrination at every
level of society because they have kids
they have nieces and nephews and they
don't like what's going on
so here's my question to hillary okay we
can agree that these issues
these issues are not going to work out
well for democrats we know that she
knows it democrats know that same
democrats know that biden doesn't know
it because he's lost in space but
everyone around him also believe me they
know it
they know it they're gonna have to walk
this back somehow and put emphasis on
something else i don't know maybe
another pandemic will pop up just in
time for the re-election campaign who
knows what's coming
then we can stoke fear in everyone and
make it an us versus them mentality and
make everybody hate each other and hide
in their houses on lockdowns and we need
big daddy government to come in and
rescue everyone maybe that'll happen
i don't know
could happen
just be prepared if it does because last
time a lot of us weren't prepared okay
myself included
so what should democrats be talking
about i would say to her hillary what
are what are the strengths what are the
strengths i want to know i'm genuinely
curious what a democrat would say and
maybe we'll have one on here and we can
talk about what their strengths are
because when i think of strengths i'm
like okay are you going to talk about
school choice no
they don't believe in that
are you going to talk about how the
lockdowns
were problematic for society and all the
ramifications well no they advocated for
them
okay are you going to talk about gas
prices and energy independence well no
they're not exactly you know part of the
drill baby drill crowd
so what are you going to talk about
because it seems to me that what happens
is is that democrats can't talk about
these big issues because they lose the
economy you can talk about the economy
well
it's not going so well for a lot of
people for a lot of people
so what happens is they can't talk about
the economy they can't talk about gas
prices they can't talk about oil so
they're like oh let's talk about gender
let's talk about gender
let's let's do let's talk about this
over here we can rile everybody up we
can say that desantis hates gay people
let's go with that
that's the strategy
really i invite you at home to think
about this question what are the
strengths of the democrat party today
what are they
i i mean i would love to hear back in
the in the chat in the comments tell me
what you think democrats out there i
hope you're listening i love it if
you're here you know i love a good
debate
put it in the chat tell me what the
strengths are i want to hear
i think she'd have a hard time on here
if i asked her i don't know last time i
asked hillary a question i lost my job a
few days later so who knows
maybe tyler would fire me after this one
all right
so bottom line is
nobody care nobody in the democrat party
cares about hillary clinton's advice
they don't care they're just like they
don't know how to tell her hillary do us
a favor and please don't run again
because she's bad at this and i don't
care whether you agree with her
politically whether you agree with her
policy maybe you didn't think it was a
big problem that she lied about the
email scandal
maybe you didn't think that she threw
somebody else under the bus during
benghazi maybe you didn't find a problem
with that i did maybe you didn't maybe
you agree with her on big government
policies that's your thing
okay
maybe you do but the bottom line is
she's a bad candidate she's bad at
politics she's bad at running for
something bad
really really bad at it
i had a teacher once that used to say
when you if you're really bad at
something someone should tell you
someone should tell you that's not to
say you can't shoot for the stars you
can't oh dream big and
but if you can't sing at all
at all
and you want to win american idol
there's going to have to be a reality
check moment with you at some point
somebody needs to tell her she's bad at
this and i think democrats huddle every
now and then and just say please please
it's not going to be her please
dear heavens
the only person they were more afraid of
than her was bernie
remember they took bernie out remember
that the dnc took bernie out twice twice
because they knew well he's too extreme
he's not going to win over the
independence hillary's better i don't
know man
bernie is at least a guy who he speaks
and you're like that guy believes what
he's saying
there's at least that hillary i don't
know that just looks like an empty
vessel to me sorry to say but
that's not where the democrat party is
the democrat party is not a hillary
clinton party right now they don't care
what her opinion is they're probably
like why did somebody ask her for this
interview who cares she's not the woman
of the moment she's not in the mood of
the moment when it comes to democrats
they're not there they're more in line
with aoc and the people people who
menstruate
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
you